- Okay, so Quintessa, you are one
of the first non-binary
actors to play a superhero
in the DC universe, so
what does that mean to you?
It's gotta feel pretty cool.
- I think maybe I'm one of the first.
I'm out, so that's one thing.
There could be people who are questioning
or still figuring what that means to them
and their gender identity,
but for me, I think it's an incredibly,
I don't take it lightly
I think because as a young kid,
I never would've thought
that someone who's non-binary
or trans could be open
enough with who they are
and showcase who they are globally
and get far and be able to do the things
that they've always dreamt of
and just fully just embrace who they are.
So I think being here and being out
and discussing these things
and even you asking that
question is so important
because there could be
a young trans person
or someone who's just questioning
who needs to see themselves represented
in some sort of way just to know
that they can do anything
that they dreamt of.
- Absolutely, inclusivity.
(audience cheering)